rosie what's next well you know it is
holiday party season so we're digging
into some big food faux pas in today's
food news
everyone's going to holiday parties have
you been invited to a bunch yet off
holiday parties no oh
well that's a store subject okay well i
didn't i mean i haven't been invited to
one holiday party i did i almost assumed
they weren't happening well it's been a
bit since we've had some but i'm ready
for a holiday party have you gotten
invited to a holiday now that i think
about it no thanks for bringing it up
well um i can't wait for holiday party
and better homes and gardens reports a
survey of a thousand people tackled this
subject listen to this do you know how
many people admitted to doing the worst
thing double dipping at a party
36
of people
say that they double dip at a party you
are disgusting
not that i would ever judge you but
um
47
admit to talking with their mouth full
which okay i do that we're human come on
and 28 of people admit to
i can't believe this touching a piece of
food and then putting it back what is
wrong with you
[Music]
um and if you're if you're guilty of any
of these food faux pas watch out because
more than half of the people surveyed
say they remember they they got your
eyes on you and if you do it you're not
invited next year okay
what drew are you guilty of any of these
things um
i
just have to say that i am so
anti-double dipping thank you and don't
you even reverse by taking a bite and
then turning it around and then dipping
the other end in
don't do that that's not
that's the same as double dip not my
name is lick it while you're at it well
gabriel guevara in our audience he has
some thoughts about this and i'm really
excited gabriel you know i'm a double
dipper i gotta say it's it should be
expected
a dish with dip the dip is the best part
of the dish right you're gonna go back
for more if you have leftover cracker i
really like you because of your truth
and
i just appreciate it because so many
people are like oh i would never do that
and then they go and do it good for you
for your honesty thanks yeah it's
expected and
i will say
that lately i've been doing this thing
because i'm a huge guacamole fanatic yes
i'd now do small little bowls of
guacamole
so everyone has their individual yeah
you take it and you just
yeah away that's a great move too at a
party and gabriel i want you and
especially if gabriel's coming over i'm
gonna have those little bowls
and that's you're exactly the person
that inspired me and i didn't even know
you yet but i know you now and i
i love your truth and i'm going to take
preventative measures yeah
understood you're going to get your own
preventative measures yeah but thank you
because like everybody lies
listen you know what gabriel we've been
leaving some crumbs on this desk all
week long because it's cookie week yes
now get ready
to unleash your inner cookie monster
cookie monster
i'm good i used to do it better for the
kids do it one more time cookie like
milk cookie
okay like cookie
why do you sound like yoda
[Laughter]
you are way more yoda than ski monster
well this this company called
my cookie dealer wow that took a turn
um and it's but i have to say i'm
obsessed with this company and check it
out so you know how like there are
sneaker heads and people have like
exciting new sneakers and people wait
around the corner and lines to get it
okay well this long island couple juan
and karen morale are basically doing
that for cookies they started their
pandemic business small selling their
massive cookies in plastic baggies out
of their trunk at one's bodybuilder
competitions
and now they ship all over the country
and you can only order them on instagram
really and there's two cookie drops
every week and they're always different
and they sell out like that
i know how cool is that okay so we get
to try some of these bad boys right now
cookie
gabriel do you want to finish my cookies
hang on
hurry up
oh god
that's how i feel about double dipping
well i just want to thank the team at my
cookie dealer and i gotta tell you
i'm hooked they're delish
[Applause]
[Music]